اسمح لي ان اخصص جزء من هذا الحوار
لعلاقتك بافغانستان انت كنت سفير هناك
وكنت المبعوث الخاص لرئيس جورج بوش
للتنسيق مع المعارضه الافغانيه بعد هجوم
سبتمبر 2001 الارهابي كيف تقيم عملك الان
بعد مرور اثنين وعشرين عاما على ذلك
لا نستطيع تجنب الاستنتاج من ان
الجهود حققت فشلا في النهايه حققت
ازدهار لافغانستان في البدايه
وهناك ضعف الاشخاص الذي يستطيعون القراءه
في افغانستان اليوم مقارنه ب 2001
واغلبه الافغانيين لديهم امكانيه الوصول
الى الانترنت وحتى لديهما هواتفان قال لم
بكل لديهم اي هواتف في عام 2001 كما ان
معدلات الاعمار ايضا ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا
وافغانستان حققت تقدم من اكثر في على
العقد الاول بعد عام 2001 او اكثر من اي
دوله اخرى اما الان فهي تقاس بقاعده بطيئه
جدا ولا تزال بين افقر الدول في العالم
ولكن حصل تغيير كبيره جدا في ظروف الشعب
الافغاني والان
عادوا الى حيثما كانوا قبل 20 عاما من
الان وهذا مخيب للاعمال اعتقد بان
الولايات المتحده اخطات في حساباتها
عندما اعتقد ان هذه الشراكه قد تكون
مستدامه وان افغانستان ستكون قادره
على
الاعتماد على نفسها وعدم الاعتماد على
المساعدات الغربيه
يعني تتحمل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الجزء الاكبر من هذه الكارثه الانسانيه
التي تعاني منها افغانستان الان
نحن بالتاكيد نتحمل مسؤوليه ولكن
المسؤوليه الاساسيه تقع على عاتقه
الطالبان هم الذين استولوا على الحكم وليس
نحن
ولكن نعم نستطيع ان نقول بان الولايات
المتحده مسؤوله عن تصرفاتها
ونستطيع ان
او نحكم على سياسات الولايات المتحده حسب
النتائج والنتائج مخيبه